I read with Scott Speedman I didn't get
it that was one that I turned down and
one that I wish I'd gotten remember
being devastated as a kid nine stars
spilling on the roll that got away
up first Adam Brody who may not have
played the OCS have Cohen if this
happened first audition that you ever
went on
oh no I want to think of this this is
great I like that question I think the
Power Rangers maybe definitely Dawson's
Creek I read with Scott Speedman I
didn't get it
no no no after is like later on but I am
that was like my first like it felt like
was real TV show
imagine Christina Applegate doing the
bend and snap and Legally Blonde
so you been oh yeah the script came
along my way and it was right after I
just finished married I don't remember
it but it was just I got scared I got
scared of kind of repeating myself
stupid move that was right picture big
without Tom Hanks well there was big
that's one that was for you yeah you're
gonna be Tom Hanks yeah Hunger Games
also almost had a very different stars
one that would have been great was
Hunger Games that were then awesome
which were all Peeta
Wow Peter breath but now I didn't you
you mean coulda woulda shoulda it's yeah
but it's like they are the movies great
josh is great and The Chronicles of
Narnia films could have had a different
lead ooh I really wanted to play it was
a Narnia movie the Prince Caspian film I
think I did I auditioned for the Prince
Caspian family really yeah I think Ben
Barnes almost really good and it's been
bombs
ya know I really just wanted that part
and I think I think someone said oh you
know I think the feedback was oh he's
not handsome enough about you know come
on what can you do hey that was what I
was just trying out I was like my god
Narnia I love Daniel
Mayim Bialik almost lived a blossom las'
life
I remember being devastated as a kid for
it I'm not getting blossom oh my gosh
that one hurt
can you imagine oh I would have rocked
that hat but it all worked yeah my I'm
did really Oliver Hudson blew our minds
when he admitted to skipping an audition
to play Jack Pearson on this is us yeah
I mean I I was supposed to have a
chemistry read you know who knows if I
would have gotten the show but I was
scheduled for a 10-day fishing trip and
I loved the fish and I loved the script
but I love to fish
and I chose fishing and I love Milo I
know him and he's amazing and that's the
role that he should be doing the
bull's-eyed Katie Stephens went out for
Nashville more than once I've auditioned
for Nashville a million times I've
always liked which I'm always like I
love Nashville that would've been so
great but again it's not it wasn't right
for me at that time because when I
didn't get Nashville the first time I
got faking it wait and when I hang at
Nashville a second time I got this so
it's it's you know I feel like
everything happens for a reason and
finally well we heard matt LeBlanc
almost played ty Burrell's role on
Modern Family
Leslie Grossman was being considered for
Julie Bowling's part I tested for Modern
Family and I did not get it and that was
tough they were lovely and they brought
me back and and I guest-starred in an
episode but Julie Bowen scared Tom which
of course that was always gonna be a
Julia bones character and once you see
who gets that you're like well that
makes perfect sense that was one of
those times where I may have gotten in
bed I pulled the covers over my head for
just a few minutes and then I rallied
and moved on with my life
[Music]